foreign
so we ordered a shed from overstock.com
and guess what Ryan we finally got rid
of our storage units amazing it looks
that looks like it's aesthetically
pleasing I mean no storage shed would be
better but as far as storage sheds go
like that's pretty aesthetically
pleasing man if it were up to me we
wouldn't have a storage shed at all the
only thing I keep in there is a large 24
inch broom that I use to sweep the patio
regularly but before we had the shed I
just leaned it against the side of the
house or no one would see it and it was
an aesthetically pleasing broom
obviously because I I you know I'll tell
you I'll put a link to the specific
broom that I got if you're looking for
an aesthetically pleasing broom I'll do
this for you just this one time we'll
put it in the show notes podcast or the
minimalist.com podcast although you
probably don't need a new broom and so
don't just go out and impulse buy a
broom because I have this broom dude it
doesn't make you any cool it makes me
cooler but it doesn't make you any
cooler no I again like I appreciate your
attention to detail when it comes to
Aesthetics like I uh I need a new Kettle
my Kettle is finally like breaking down
it's on its last leg and I almost texted
the other day like hey what was that
cuddle that you have because it's it's a
beautiful looking Kettle and it serves a
purpose
um same thing with the shed beautiful
shed serves a purpose awesome man so you
got rid of your storage unit and all the
camping gears in there yeah so the
storage unit was bex's storage unit I
say hours because I contributed to the
monthly payment of it and so
um what we decide is we wanted to have a
shed to keep the camping gear that Bex
has and there are a few other yard
things that Bex uses for gardening and
trees and all this other stuff but up to
me it would just all these giant patio
in the backyard pour the concrete
already oh my goodness and you would
sweep it like every day yeah yeah twice
a day every day yep the more you sweep
the more you feel clean on the inside
right
there's my own illness thank you uh and
uh so this is a picture of her she shed
I have uh my own man cave he's kidding
is she shed is that like an actual term
or is it because it's yeah it is I
actually expected this this something
totally
totally backyard shed that's used as a
retreat like the fame the feminine
equivalent of a man cave right that's
why I was joking there because I don't
have a man cave she doesn't actually
have a she shed this is her shed gotcha
thing got it and uh so when you go in
there there's not like just like posters
of hot men with muscles and their shirts
off and Speedos that's what I was
expecting it's just all pictures of me
that's just really into me thank you Bax
yeah but we finally got rid of the
storage locker I want to talk about why
real quick because we were paying a
monthly fee every month it was way
cheaper than this this shed when we had
to put the shed together it shows up in
two giant very heavy boxes and and then
you have to build a foundation
underneath it as well like a gravel
foundation and what you realize is that
yes there are costs associated with
storing our things whether it is so
having that camping gear
he could have done one of three things
we could have kept it in our bedroom
just sitting there against the wall
taking up space it would have actually
become clutter at that point even though
it was useful it would have been useful
clutter because it was getting in my way
it's not useful to me and so Bex is
compassionate and understands I don't
want this to get in the way for Josh and
so we're going to temporarily put it
into a storage locker where we pay 80
bucks a month until we've saved up
enough money to not Finance but pay cash
for this shed that we can put in the
backyard we put the shed in the backyard
now all of bex's camping equipment is
there in the backyard in the shed and
also my broom which is nice and all of
her gardening equipment as well because
I don't want those things to get in the
way we bought a thing to get those
things out of the way however
I want to be clear about this I don't
want to Simply use it to hide organized
clutter these all have to be things that
still conform to our way of living which
means the just in case rule the 90 90
rule the seasonality rule the emergency
items rule these different rules that
we've implemented in our own lives that
may or may not work for you the
minimalists.com rulebook if you want to
download the free rule book for 16 rules
for a living with less and we still need
to conform to that it's getting the
things out of the way in doing so in an
aesthetically pleasing way there was
another option with that camping gear
gonna just camped out in your backyard
all the time and
but you
just enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free